[Music]
in second chance news Oh
thus chance I need like ten chances
please submitted by favorite movie dares
to back to the future I saw the devil
Princess Bride Oh what's he going good
sit good phallus a former career
shoplifter is having a hard time
providing for her six kids because no
one would give her a job anymore
I love the career shoplifter title we'll
just go back to shoplifter yeah career
criminal she gets costing you locked up
she can't be around a case is it yeah
because she has a record the three
strikes rule applies to so younger
prison yeah well she should work for
homeboy industries oh because they hire
all ex-cons or what country is this in
this is in the UK she's from London they
need a homeboy industries over there her
name is Kim she's 56 years old home
gentleman home eight home eight
industries oh yours better hold me home
bruv industries home blokes she's saying
that her 40-year shoplifting career
started when she was a child and
apparently she's saying that she's made
about three million dollars from
students from those damn she's good she
blew it all uh I know easy come easy go
I mean if she [ __ ] made that much
well I mean what three million over what
was it forty years
yeah I still not have money though two
million British pounds I just rounded it
40 years 40 years yep
that's like 6200 a month that's pretty
[ __ ] good so that's 75,000 a year
yeah so she keep on 75,000 a year
untaxed that's a lot of money
mm-hmm yeah so she appeared on a TV show
it's all I'll show you guys a clip I
would hire her for a theft prevention
yeah exactly yeah she can't she appeared
on this morning she should be a
consultant here yeah that's the problem
isn't it how do you prove that you are
now on a straight narrow and that you're
not going to be hired into someone's
home or business and strip the joint I
wouldn't do that because I've exposed
myself not you've got to be dumb today
you don't do all this and I know you
whatever I do I put everything into it
because it with the passion I saw you
somebody here know I can run a business
not darling though but it's not the
right way that was my way that's the
only way I could do it and I weren't
gonna go without nothing why should I
so she's saying that she's gonna put
passion like if someone gives her a
chance that she will put the same
passion that she put into shoplifting
into the woman what if it's not even her
like track record but she just sucks at
interviews and she's just like oh I
don't want to hire you look you could
cut you're kind of mean well she's
saying that she does get jobs but they
only last like one or two months until
their employer by her pillow or she just
sucks at working I would also be scared
if I was her that someone could use that
against me and they could like frame me
yeah exactly they could sue me for
stealing even though I didn't steal and
like it looks like I mean she just has
to go into business for herself and
consult for retail stores and these
chains and all that and be like check it
out her resume stats okay yeah I'd like
you know how much money they have to put
aside for fat it's like 10% yeah so yeah
it's a huge percent it's already
factored in the accounting because they
expect people to prevention yeah yeah I
find it pretty ridiculous that they
didn't put any subtitles on that [ __ ]
cuz I didn't understand anything top of
that when an Asian person is TV they're
just like well I went to the store and
they're like we don't know what the [ __ ]
this guy's thinking - it was hard dude -
she even says it herself like a lot of
the jobs that she's looking into the
always have all these qualifications
that you need to have she's like I can't
even speak right and she's tense
laughing you know she's applying to the
wrong places yeah yeah she could do with
like an online job too like she can do
like online consulting or some things
that's true many others wrong jobs what
kind of jobs is she looking for see
that's the real yeah she does just come
here and like auditioning at medieval
times or something and be like oh job in
a heartbeat I feel like with the
internet there's so much there's so much
you could do with the internet where you
don't have to talk like you can make
money without talking you could do like
affiliate marketing you could do like
blogging website well she's a bit older
though I feel like older people if
they're not tech savvy or they don't
like it it's like it's like reading a
book for people that hate books like I
just yeah you know yeah it's it's hard
because like sometimes like if somebody
has done something that religiously to
the point where she called it a passion
for that many years it's very hard to
believe that they're gonna cut that
habit out yeah you know what I mean I
think thoroughly enjoy cooking and food
like and let's say a job was like what
you literally can't cook your own food
I'd be you know I could say I'm not
gonna do it however it'd be very hard
for me not to that's true as soon as
she's in a place she's probably already
like scheming like oh [ __ ] I want to
take that maybe she's not but then
everyone else around her that knows is
like you just thought you're on edge and
you just have your guard up like all
right watch this let's put this stuff
away what's something that you can't go
without candy yeah well let's say the
job thing is like for the rest of your
life you're not you can't I can't do it
yeah but then but then it's it's hard
right it's very very difficult and
because she it was a passion versus a
bad habit that's the part where I'm a
little bit confused as an employer I
think that's why she's saying she's
trying to replace it like I'll put just
as much passion it's not the same I'll
replace it but I don't think it's yeah
cuz I could put as much say it like you
know what I'm gonna put as much passion
into the steak into the celery
she just needs to work out a Chinese
foot massage place where she just shut
the [ __ ] up and just [ __ ] squeeze
someone's back yeah you see the
presentation you might steal the money
out of their wallet or
be what she said that she's never stolen
from people that only she's shops
she only shop Liz oh well you know what
you know how they have secret shoppers
we should have secret Devers a chain of
retail stores I would love that like I
would hire oh no those could get a job
exactly because like you know that's
what they do for hackers it's the
government or whatever they hire you and
in there like thank you I think it's I
think it's great
give him a job because if you don't give
her a job then she's gonna get desperate
and then go back into Steven right yeah
well she says that she has written a
book about her life in that well good
for her claiming that right now it's
being considered as a how to steal for
40 years yeah I was just calling the
million I will holiday
she's never got in trouble a great title
hmm she never got told me yeah she's
gotta believe I'm a wonderfully
three-strikes doesn't go there well they
might not have the grand theft petty
theft difference there or I don't know
I'm just thinking like she might be
really smart about her thieving cuz it's
not like she's a jewelry thief right
she's just a shoplifter have you ever
caught somebody steal the stuff that she
has no I never had oh I have oh that's
all designer [ __ ] though right look at
those yeah that's did she have to pay
for it like after they caught her I'm
not sure this is a pro dude she probably
had a eBay business he came out in this
documentary and because they're like the
millionaire shopper and documentary on
his TV show so here's a screenshot from
it she looks scary listen to she looks
like she has a past yeah
would you stop somebody from stealing if
you caught them doing it in a store
depends on what the person looks like
because I thought I would see whoever is
me Oh like I was at Target and I saw
somebody like like jacking some
batteries and I just looked at him I was
like and they said we made eye contact I
won I thought I would say something but
I was like I don't know why this is not
worth my trouble yeah that's the thing
you know yes not without your business
yeah I didn't do it I kind of felt weird
about that or you might you felt bad if
you want to get shake later either yeah
I said like she asked if I saw her
stealing like would I say something like
yes definitely I saw you three no that's
racist pens too cuz if it look like a
mom-and-pop store I would say something
but it was up because there's an
attachment target so I didn't feel yeah
I would have been like I'm not saying
cuz you go excuse me and you have to
wait yet the flag somewhat like what do
you do yeah let's say I was at my
favorite sandwich shop right and then
there's like they have a wide section
they're taking a bottle of wine about
you what the [ __ ] yeah but then if it's
like at a Target I'm like sometimes it's
your state of mind like sometimes you're
just in there like if we're just
daydreaming minding your own business
but sometimes if you're more alert and
then like you have you're like I want to
be a humanitarian today you might even
be like damn man I feel bad for you well
you know what let me buy you these
batteries so I'll be a lesson to you so
that you will never have to steal ever
again there's always a way to get what
you want and they jack your wallet and
you become [ __ ] out so crazy you know
like if it's a massive retail store no
one gives a [ __ ] right huh
but if it was a mom-and-pop that you
frequent and you know the owner and and
they're jacking from the store you're
like what the [ __ ] if you like they're
jacking from you yeah the eye contact
was weird though because we he looked
directly into my soul and I look
directly into Saul's like was it like a
deer in headlights yeah and he just
looked and looked at me and I think he
expected me to say some nice one alright
was weird but we already would catch
shoplifters at your parents store I
would just look at them and they will
put it down yeah I mean what I've I've
literally caught people doing some of
the most I have stories for days about
that [ __ ] but literally first of all
immediately if you're white and you come
into the store
I don't think you're stealing some [ __ ]
just because it's a black music but
still what the [ __ ] are you doing here
unless you're a beautician so this dude
literally grabbed like this bottle of
like pro-style jail and he cupped it in
his hand this way he walks out I follow
my I see him throw it in this car he
turns around just put it back bro
because number one I don't like calling
the cops I don't like making a [ __ ]
scene my thing is just put it back come
back another day because I don't want to
say like people make mistakes but it's
like why cause I seen about this [ __ ]
you know
but we've had people even when I do that
we're just like hey we're not gonna call
the cops just put it back and get out
the store they'll [ __ ] flip the [ __ ]
out start throwing [ __ ] on I didn't
steal nothing there's like even if you
did what's the problem you just gotta
leave and come back tomorrow yeah these
human beings are very oddly ego it's not
that we want them to come back most
likely they won't but we'll give them
the option and especially because my
family you know we're like Christian we
always believe in like second chances so
for me to like my thing is like you got
caught come back again people people are
very fascinating if you look at theft
it's not a thing about they have an
intent to steal people will do stuff
because they can get away with it and
it's oh yeah it's very [ __ ] Winona Ryder
yeah we've had customers who've come
into our store since I've seen this as
they were teens great rapport we have
conversations we go into the bath that
we come back out on our shits con and
they stole it and it wasn't it wasn't
because they wanted to steal it's just
that I can't you know and they'll do it
so it's just one of those type of
situations yeah
[Music]
[Music]